one of kaisers muddiest aircraft is attacked
by british fighter plane this is London Blitz
but this is also 1916 and bombs dropped
on British capital are not blockbusters
they're House Records though and here's
sort of damage they did London suburb of
ifs which know no walls of building are
still standing and no wonder for this
is size of bombs so impotent that in many
cases such as these they don't even go off
near ammunition dump at Malden one bomb
exploded and did local damage so local the
building merely collapsed from shock of the
blast but rain of German bombs was serious
business in Britain even in first world war
little dreaming of the two-ton giant and city
smashers to come in Hitler's time English
civilians organize and drill for bomb and
invasion attack fight brigades are their
mobile units and men of Yarmouth marched
in battle of britain that was a holiday
compared with the catastrophe to come